Now we're gonna look at creating the score and time pickup.
This is gonna act as the object
that we place inside of the world
that the user will run into
and then fire off the different variables or values
that we want for our score and our time.
And to do this, what we're gonna do
is we're first gonna create
a new blueprint based off of actor.
So let's pop over to the editor now.
We can close whatever blueprints we have open.
We're gonna hit control space
and then we're gonna navigate up to our content folder.
We're gonna right click and go blueprint class.
And then from the pick parent class,
we're gonna select our actor
and we're gonna call this one BP underscore pickup.
Now, once we've done that,
we're gonna go ahead and double click on it
to open it up.
And we're gonna need to do a few things to this.
So first off, we're gonna need to put two things on this.
We're gonna need to put a sphere collision
and some type of static mesh.
And the things are gonna work like this.
The sphere collision is what we're gonna use
to notify our system
when the user has actually collided with this.
And the static mesh is gonna represent
a visual representation of that.
So we have something to look at in the world.
So let's go ahead and set that up now.
So inside of our pickup, let's go add.
We're gonna look for a SPH
and we want the sphere collision.
I'm also gonna make sure I have it selected
when it's added and change its radius here to 96.
And the other thing that I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna add a cube right here.
And that's just gonna add a static mesh.
It's the same as adding a static mesh.
This just does it in one step for us.
So the next thing that we're gonna be doing
is we're gonna take our sphere here.
And one of the cool things about many of the objects
that you add inside of Blueprints is if you select them
and then you go over to the details panel under events,
you're gonna find a whole bunch of different events
that you can use to interact with this.
And the event that we want is this on component
begin overlap of our sphere collision.
So let's go over to the editor again,
select our sphere collision and the details panel.
We're gonna come all the way down to the bottom
and we're gonna look for our on component begin overlap.
I'm gonna press this plus right here.
And what that's gonna do is it's gonna bring us over
to the event graph and boom, right there,
we have our on component begin overlap sphere.
Now, the next part of this involves us setting up
an interface check and then a branch condition
as well as creating some variables.
So let's take a look at our logic
before we set everything up.
What we're gonna basically doing is when we overlap this,
we are gonna look at the other actor.
So what actor overlapped this?
Does that actor implement our vehicle interface
or BPI vehicle interface?
Using the branch condition, if it does,
then we are going to add a score and a time
to our blueprint interface, which is gonna signal
our code that we should increment our time and our score.
So let's do this in the editor now.
So what we're gonna do is I'm just gonna pull
my details panel over a little bit.
So I have a little more real estate.
So we're gonna pull off of this
and we're gonna look for our branch node.
It'd help if I spell that, right?
So there we go, branch, there we go.
And then on our other actor, we're gonna pull off
and we're gonna look for, it does.
And right there under utilities, does implement interface.
We're gonna under interface select class,
we're gonna look for our BPI.
And there we go, there's our BPI vehicle.
So that's the interface that we want.
And then we wanna take the return value
and plug that in right here to our condition.
Okay, and the next thing that we're gonna do
is when this is true, we're gonna pull off
and we're gonna look for picked up and there we go,
class BPI vehicle picked up objects message.
And now we need to fill in a few things here.
The other actor is the target here, right?
Because that is the actor that is making
that request there.
So we need to make sure that that is filled in.
And then our score and our time,
here's a little thing that we can do here.
We wanna fill these in,
but there's two things that we wanna do.
We want to turn these to variables,
but we also wanna expose those variables
so that they can be modified.
So first off, let's right click on these
and go promote to variable,
and then do the same thing for time.
So now we have a time and a score.
Now to make these variables so that we can modify them
when we're placed in the level,
all we need to do is make sure
that the instance editable option is set,
or we click on this little eyeball next to the variables
to turn them from private variables into public variables.
So let's do that now, we'll select time,
and then we'll come here and we'll do instance editable.
And then for score, we can just come over here
and press this little eyeball.
And it does the exact same thing.
So if we have both of these selected,
we won't be able to do anything.
But again, we can select the time
and make it instance editable or public
by pressing this eyeball, or we can select the score
and again, instance editable will make this public.
Now once we're done with that,
we do need to compile and save.
And the next and last thing we're gonna do
is we're gonna add this destroy actor.
So what this does is basically once we run into this,
it should destroy this or remove it from the world.
So let's go ahead and try to add that now.
So we're just gonna pull off of our picked up objects,
we're gonna look for destroy.
And there under actor, we have our destroy actor.
So let's just compile and save.
I'm gonna close this.
And what should happen now is
if I bring up my BP pickup here,
we're gonna hit run and all the way over there.
Now I'm not gonna see any updates,
but I should see it disappear.
So if you see it disappear, that is what we want.
We want it to do that disappearing act for us.
That way we can make sure that everything is working.
And what you're seeing me do here now,
just a little pro tip is I was really far away.
I'm gonna make it a little easier to test that, right?
So all I did is I just press play.
When I escaped from play,
it brings me back over here to where the play was.
So now I'm in that area in the editor,
and then I just dragged my actor into there
to make it a little bit easier.
So, all right, that is it for this section.
In our next section, we're gonna take a look
at adding motion graphics and UI to this
using UMG or Unreal motion graphics.